nicolas duvernois diane bérard bonsoir
on ça nicolas d'abord est-ce qu amazon
est devenue une entreprise trop grande
non on fait toujours l'erreur de
regarder amazon comme étant une entité
unique surtout celles qu'on compense qui
est vraiment le monstre tel qu on le
détruit un peu partout qui est la
plateforme de commerce électronique le
amazon.com ou rechercher nos brevets
sans guillemets mais amazon c'est une
myriade d'entreprises qui vont du
supermarché pour le food au service
d'info nuagiques à l'eau plate formes
telles preuves vidéos et bien sûr des
magasins aussi dans d'autres pays
oui des magasins physiques donc le site
web amazon en tant que tel le e-commerce
c'est représente un peu moins de la
moitié de ses revenus totaux
donc si elle est trop grosse mais il ya
énormément d'entreprises quand même qui
seraient trop grosse il ya des walmart
qui serait trop gros il y aurait
beaucoup d'autres joueurs donc c'est
juste 200 milliards sur les 400 qui sont
dans le commerce en ligne est ce que
c'est trop gros dia définitivement c'est
la troisième plus grosse entreprise au
monde 1.3 million d'employés quand on
inclut les employés à temps partiel
amazon s'est infiltré dans tous les
aspects de notre vie dans tous les pays
le seul pays qui résistaient c'est la
chine avec son propre écosystème qui
s'appelle ali baba mais pourquoi la
chine a résisté pour deux raisons
d'abord syndicature donc ils peuvent
imposer leur loi et deuxièmement une
barrière linguistique qui fait que les
chinois sont prisonniers de l'écosystème
alibaba donc oui c'est trop gros j'ai
l'impression quand on regarde ça c'est
quand même la troisième plus grosse
entreprise au monde qu'on vit dans un
monde de science fiction que ce que je
dis je pense que je suis la seule
personne que je connais que jamais rien
acheté sur amazon je sais pas combien de
temps je vais résister encore mais
malgré l'euphorie
non j suracheté j'en ai pas besoin de ce
qu'il ya sur amazon je le trouve
ailleurs mais objectivement l'impression
qu'on vit dans un film de science
fiction
quand on nous prédit qu'ils vont rester
une entreprise par fekter
à force de consolidation qui
d'acquisitions et que les gouvernements
vont laisser aller leur poids à ses
entraîneurs
quand on regarde la taille de
l'entreprise gigantesque on évoque
amazon dans quelques années pour détenir
20% des ventes au détail aux états unis
un moment donné ça s'appelle qui
jouerait à 45,45 quoi ils ont déjà 45%
du commerce électronique aux états unis
si ça ne s'appelle plus de la
concurrence là mais la seule chose qui
nous avons un monopole est chose qu'il
est sensé que sont pas le monopole au
centre et parce que monopole ça empêche
de la concurrence or les pme
bon sur amazon sauf qu'elles sont captés
ce qui les attire dans sa toile donc oui
il ya neuf cent mille emplois qui ont
été créés dans des pme traces amazon
tout ça mais ils sont dans son univers à
ces conditions donc à quelqu'un parce
qu'on vire est démantelé une maison de
nicolas bay non parce que là on dit au
monde de se lancer en affaires d'un côté
mais si tu réussis trop et on va
démanteler ça venait même à kalaya trop
iliad romain sarels 5000 ouais mais qui
met trop et trop c'est quattro si le
goff pendant 20 ans était dans son
garage a essayé de bâtir une entreprise
mais l'on voit le punir parce qu'il
réussit moi sincèrement je vois pas le
problème est ce qu'on veut fermer google
de ce qu'on veut fermer facebook on veut
tout le monde dit on veut fermer mais
finalement tout le monde danse trois
heures par jour sur la plate forme donc
abandonné moi je crois que la
problèmatique le diane c'est que le
monde
ils ont un peu peur de ce monstre de
l'envergure qui craint mais alors qu'on
mette nos clubs piqué le gouvernement
mettre des lois pour réglementer sicile
c'est ces entreprises qui deviennent
plus grands ils prennent le g7 tout seul
jack buser c'est quand même un mélange
bien pensants d'accord avec ça québécois
qui vivent grâce à amazon sur le monde
ils savent pas ce qu'il pense qu'amazon
a créé tout ce qui vend mais pas toutes
dionne c'est vrai qu amazon est une
plate forme mais à quelque part quand ça
devient comme une marque de commerce
c'est comme veulent acheter sur amazon
quand c'est leur réflexe il ya quelques
jours monopolistique dans cette cantine
et le gouvernement devrait réglementer
mais si le gouvernement réglemente
parce que c'est rendu trop c'est sinon
pourquoi le gouvernement s'engagerait le
gouvernement se mêle pas alors donc à
quelques pas de chez nous john continue
je disais juste que si subtile riffier
qu'ils avaient le gouvernement de
réglementer c'est parce que ça a fait
une tête plein et à tous on sait même
plus une multinationale s'est rendu
planète a donc à quelques pas je
reconnais que les pme vente sur amazon
donc à quelque temps il ya point de
salut un dard d'amazon qu'est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle qu amazon
achète jenks bande requis thelma louise
thelma et louise robocop terminateur
nicolas est ce que le consommateur que
je suis que nous sommes est gagnant
aujourd'hui oui non et gagnant parce que
bon il va avoir une avalanche de
conclure
et puis je suis sûr qu'ils vont vers les
aider ils vont faire des robocop 22h06
sont rendus là alors il va avoir un peu
de divertissement pour tout le monde
cependant le 9 milliards attention là
amazon c'est celui qu'il avance mais il
est personne qu'il paye
et bien c'est nous tous ou au lieu de
payer 9 95 où je suis combien ça coûte
par mois ben tout d'un coup on va se
réveiller le 1er janvier salle ont coûté
11 et 25 donc c'est sûr et certain qu'on
va le payer à la fin toute cette guerre
de contenu surtout que vu qu'ils
regardent pour le contenu mais ils ont
payé une surprime pour avoir ce contenu
ils ont payé plus cher parce que ça vaut
vraiment ce campus mgm avait des 10 et
donc c'est sûr qu'on va le payer mais
pour le divertissement césar avait
raison c'est quoi donner de la bourse bd
et des jeux diversité mondiale
enfin jeff bezos devrait s'appeler
wimbée césar vous offre en donne
beaucoup
comment on resta ça nous les
francophones avec la culture nous
essaierons du gros diane comment on fait
comment on fait mais je pense que c'est
pas une qu'on peut parler de compétition
je pense qu est peut-être des publics
différents
je pense qu'un problème peut-être de
mise en marché parce que leurs réflexes
netflix est aussi fort que le réflexe
amazon
pourtant il ya plein de production de
qualité au québec je peux nommer fragile
montante sujet
mais face il y en a des tonnes il ya une
question peut être de mise en marché
peut-être que les lancements sont plus
discrets peut-être que le réflexe
m'explique c'est tellement installés qui
on peut pas aller chercher une certaine
clientèle
il ya aussi une question technologique
pour préparer la chronique j'en parlais
avec mon conjoint des seals and i les
plateformes y québécoise anne eu
beaucoup qui plante souvent donc il me
parlait de robustesse de la technologie
je sais toujours pas ce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai signé chez
certaines personnes m'ont cité c'est un
enjeu mais objectivement qu'on était
vraiment de concurrence et le contenu
des clips avec ce curseur et nico tous
pointé vie je pense pas parce qu'on va
chercher dont jours et donc qui a ses
pommes il faut être complémentaires
il nous reste une minute je ne peux pas
rendre justice aux prochains sujets dont
je vous demande une réponse courte
nicolas objectif lune pour ou contre
l'idée que le canada investisse 37
millions de dollars depuis le début 2020
dans l'exploration spatiale la conquête
de la lune alors qu'on a des besoins de
terrain portant mais vous êtes vous pour
ou contre ça totalement contre moi je
crois qu'on devrait prendre cet argent
là et l'investir pour aider nos
entreprises de l'industrie aérospatiale
d'aller chercher et de développer des
collaborations d'aller chercher les
contrats avec des nasa ou des spacek ce
monde qui font des milliards pour aller
se promener dans l'espace avec 36
millions chemin pas de celle ci pour
elle pour juste pour payer l'essence
pour aller sur la lune si on essaye de
jouer il a définitivement dans une autre
ligue dionne s'est pas beaucoup d'argent
mais je suis pour le fait d'aller dans
l'espace à condition que ce soit pour
une conquête que ce soit pour aller
développer des technologies qui vont
être développés dans notre qui vont être
implantés dans notre quotidien après
sommet dans un esprit de conquête
parce que les autres le font parce
qu'une course aso non on est libre de
choisir le développement économique on
veut qui s'est pas effectivement avec ce
montant alors qu'on va faire une
différence
mais par contre si il ya des projets
technologiques qui peuvent revenir dans
notre quotidien créé ou et qui sait oui
mais en plus on peut pas être contre le
fait qu'amazon devient trop grand quand
on sait que plusieurs milliards de ses
revenus
une entreprise pour aller dans l'espace
puis de l'autre côté pitch 40 millions à
la psp réinventer la lune ce qui va se
développer
la nasa ou spacek sous je suis pas quel
autre pays allait se masse et bien
abandonnés çà va être aussi disponible
pour nous je crois qu'il faudrait des
partenaires et qui sait peut-être amazon
pourra livrer sur la lune éventuellement
un calicot ans a commandé à 24 ans 24
heures exactement important merci vous
êtes formidables à l'asmo bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit